the aoc squad takes retaliatory measures
against President Trump Trump declares
victory and Bernie Sanders is fading
down the stretch this is the Ben Shapiro
show
all right it's been a long day already
the reason that it has been a long day
already I'm I don't mean to bore you
with details of my personal life suffice
it to say that I only fell asleep around
one o'clock in the morning because I
came home yesterday afternoon and went
to our little guest house out in the
back and it turns out that we had a
mainline backup and that meant that
sewage was spilling all over the floor
so insurance claim complete replacement
of the floor in the in the guest house
the reason I say this is because it was
a total crap show and that provides a
transition to today's political show
because just as my guest house was
filled with open sewage so too is modern
American politics
so you'll last recall that when we left
a riveting story the aoc Nancy Pelosi
battle has evolved into a Donald Trump
versus everybody battle because
President Trump decided to jump in on
Sunday and suggest that a bunch of
Congress people should go back to their
home countries the only problem being
that the vast majority of the people he
was talking about were born right here
in the United States also telling people
to go back to their countries is
typically not a non-racial non zero
became to do so it was a bad comment by
the President of the United States but
if there is one thing that we can count
on in today's politics is that if
somebody jumps on a rake their political
opponent will immediately find a larger
and dumber rake to jump upon if Donald
Trump says to aoc hold my beer AOC will
immediately turn back to him and say no
you hold my beer and so late last night
about 2 p.m. Pacific time about 5 p.m.
Eastern the squad the so-called squad
this would be a Ossie and Rasheeda Talib
and ohon Omar and then the Ringo Starr
of the Beatles Ayanna Presley they
decided to hold a press conference and
their press conference was designed to
go after president from now president
from somehow may have been able to pull
victory out of the jaws of defeat that
he had pulled out of the jaws of victory
to reverse engineer this Russian doll of
politics basically he had a victory AOC
and Nancy Pelosi were going at each
other with hatchets and then he pulled
defeat out of those jaws by inserting
himself and making xenophobic comments
and then he was able to pull victory out
of that because aoc Rasheeda Talib Ilhan
Omar and Ayanna Presley are truly
unlikable truly
popular and that is not coming from just
my partisan conservatism that is coming
via poll data so just a day before all
of this broke out Mike Allen of Axios
reported that internal democratic polls
showed that the more people saw of AOC
the less they liked Democrats this is
according to Axios democrats are
sounding the alarm that swing voters
know and dislike socialism warning it
could cost them the house and the
presidency the poll is making the rounds
of some of the most influential
Democrats in America if all voters hear
about his AOC it could put the House
Majority at risk set a top Democrat
involved in 2020 congressional races
she's getting all the news and defining
everyone else's races the poll was taken
in May before Pelosi even went at it
with AOC and the rest of the squad by
the way is there anything more obnoxious
in politics than people turning
themselves the squad remembers obnoxious
when we had the gang of eight like
they're walking around like the Jets in
West Side Story talking about
immigration but now we actually have the
squad which apparently comes directly
from Mean Girls so you've got the the
kind of lead character throws her hair
over her shoulder that's AOC and then
you've got the quiet smart one and that
would be Rasheeda Talib and then you got
the one who sends me notes to everybody
that's el hanout Omar and then you just
have the one who's just sort of there
and this Iona Presley so the squad was
pulled okay and there's a poll and what
it showed is it included a thousand
three likely general election voters who
are white and have two years or less of
college education so that would be a
crowd that Democrats do need to win
these are the white non college voters
who embraced Trump in 2016 but Democrats
need in those swing house districts
according to Axios the group that took
the poll shared the results who were the
findings AOC was recognized by 74
percent of voters in the poll 22 percent
had a favorable view it's a brutal
numbers Ilhan Omar another member of the
squad because they're so cool man
they're so cool
they passed notes and about on the
cheerleading team and they're also part
of Model UN they're the best
Ilhan Omar was recognized by 53 percent
of the voters nine percent not a typo
since Mike Allen had a favorable view so
nobody likes AOC nobody likes so hen
Omar
so Trump by picking a fight with these
people may have done himself a service
in the end even though he did it in the
dumbest possible way why because the
more people see of these folks
the less they like them and the more
they are linked to the Democratic hopes
the less people are likely to vote for
Democrats so that's why President Trump
has basically shifted his tactic as we
will see from go back to your home
country to if you don't like the country
then leave right which is a non
xenophobic non racist pitch it's not a
particularly profirstaid men pitch I
mean how do you distinguish between
criticism of the country that is
legitimate and criticism of the country
that is illegitimate how do you decide
who should leave and who shouldn't I
mean president Trump has criticized the
country should he leave them in it's
sort of a weak argument overall but it
does have an emotional resonance when
you have people who speak about America
in general the way AOC and Ilhan Omar
and Talib and Ayana Presley talk about
America as a place rife with horror as a
place that is rooted and steeped in evil
and xenophobia and cruelty it's
particularly galling coming from Ilhan
Omar who is taken in by this country if
you were taken in by the country because
you came from a place that was truly a
hellhole and Somalia is a hellhole she
spent years in a in a refugee camp in
Kenya and it's hard to describe that as
anything else in a hellhole and then she
comes to the greatest country on the
planet and is elected to Congress and
then you talk about how terrible the
country is a lot of people are gonna say
just leave then you don't like it just
go right and then that is what Trump is
now trying to more of his original
xenophobic tweets into and that one has
a lot more emotional resonance even
though intellectually speaking we
shouldn't be playing the game of you
disagree with me so you should leave
right so in a second we're going to get
to a OC and the squad really shooting
themselves in the foot because this is
now what we have we have a competition
for who can shoot themselves in the foot
the most we'll get to that in just a
second first let me tell you something I
work out a lot okay work out every
single day which is why I am ripped
beyond your possible imagination but
here is the thing I want my workout
clothes to be as comfortable and as
practical as possible no bull it's a
footwear apparel and accessory brand
I've been looking for and I just got
these shoes from a bull check these
things out what do these kits mean that
is some stylish stuff right here leave
that flexibility as well but check out
those kicks they have great stuff over
at Noble okay they've got the simple
design but the simple design isn't the
whole deal no Bulls gear is built to
perform launched in 2015 no bull has
disrupted the fitness industry they have
a practical philosophy don't put
anything on that doesn't do anything
take everything off that you don't need
be honest about what the product does
that's what no bull does their training
gear is designed to perform for you when
and where you need them that's it so if
you're ready to challenge your gear the
way you challenge yourself go to noble
project comm slash Shapiro today for
people who put in the work day after day
visit noble project comm slash up hero
check out their training gear that is n
OB UL l PR oj ec t noble project comm
bat slash shapiro and check out their
training he does all awesome stuff we
got the shores about the shirt the gear
is just great you're gonna love it noble
project comm backslash Shapiro so go
check them out right now okay so
president Trump jumps into it and all of
yesterday all we hear about is every
Republican being asked whether he's a
racist whether he's a xenophobe and then
the squad take the stage and here's the
thing about the squad the squad are very
popular in their own minds they're very
popular among a particularly cliquish
segment of American society that segment
by the way is not minority America so
the idea that the squad is deeply
approved of inside minority America is
not particularly true the people who
really love the squad are the writers
over at Vox there are the people over at
the New York Times editorial board there
are people who are an upper upper class
white liberal enclaves those are the
people who love the squad because
they're photogenic and because they
speak truth to power and because they
clap back man they clap back they shoot
with fire
they're just fire all the time that
that's who loves these folks no one else
does as it turns out the statistics on
them garbage so let's say you're Nancy
Pelosi and let's say the Donald Trump
steps directly in it what would be your
next move really strategically speaking
what you want to do is minimize these
for being at the front of your party
well at the same time pointing out that
Donald Trump just once again said
something xenophobic and in Nancy
Pelosi's view racist so you'd want to
highlight that so maybe what you do is
you hold a press conference where the
squad is there but Nancy Pelosi does the
talking to show unity right that's what
you'd want to do also there's some point
there's something that is that is deeply
off-putting about the I'm a victim
routine you see from so many members of
Congress where somebody is insulted
thence like I'm going into a press
conference talking about how victimized
and insulted I am and look at me
standing up to my aggressor
listen there play
people who are out there coming out of
the woodwork defending the squad them
defending themselves actually looks
pretty opportunistic politically
speaking
so the squad immediately decided you
know it'd be a great idea we're gonna go
out there and we're gonna be so radical
and off-putting that we make Donald
Trump's if you don't like America leave
message sound kind of plausible that's
what the squad just did yesterday so
they started off and wasn't that bad so
they started off with their that our
little press conference and they started
off on sort of the right track
politically speaking talking about all
of the things they love about America
which is that they are here apparently
that's pretty much it and they talk
about the inclusivity of America so here
is a OSI leading this thing off this
thing starts off on the rails and then
it goes quickly wildly off the rails so
here is a OSI yesterday saying this
country belongs to everyone in Trump's
non unifying messages alienating people
the first note that I want to tell
children across this country is that no
matter what the president says this
country belongs to you and it belongs to
everyone and today that notion that very
notion was challenged this weekend that
very notion was challenged so I am NOT
surprised when if when the president
says that for sitting members of
Congress should quote go back to their
own country when he has authorized raids
without warrants on thousands of
families across this country okay so she
starts off with this endless and it's
disingenuous obviously she talks about
Trump being divisive there's a lady who
suggested that we have concentration
camps on our border this is a woman
who's defended anti-semitism in her own
caucus ill gente Martin retreated to
lead are open anti-semites Ayanna
Presley the Ringo star of this band
she's standing off to the side over the
weekend she suggested that if you don't
agree with her and you're black you're
not actually black or if you don't agree
with Ilhan Omar and you're Muslim you're
not actually Muslim or if you don't
agree with the Democratic Party agenda
and you're gay you're not actually gay
and then you got a OC talking about it's
only Donald Trump who's divisive so
listen everybody knows what this game is
and everybody understands the game
especially because Nancy Pelosi came out
yesterday the Speaker of the House and
said we're going to pass a resolution
going after the
of the United States and his bigotry and
his xenophobia and his racism right she
said this yesterday well oddly enough
Nancy Pelosi couldn't even do that when
it was members of her own party almost
as though accusations of bigotry made by
members of Congress are completely a
matter of political convenience and no
one is consistent about labeling bad
stuff when they see bad stuff in
Congress almost as though this is all
partisan ridiculousness and it's all
gonna get tuned out by next week and so
as he starts off that this country
belongs her but she's messaging
correctly and then she says we're not
leaving because we're not gonna leave
the things we love she's yet to defined
the things in America that she loves but
apparently there are things I am NOT
surprised at what he's doing but I also
know that we're focused on making it
better because we don't leave the things
that we love and when we love this
country what that means is that we
propose the solutions to fix it okay so
this is the I love my country and I'm
going to fix it that's fine except that
that's not the language that these four
have been using they keep using the
language that America is awful terrible
no good very bad but again this is the
correct message and then aoc says listen
weak Minds challenged our loyalty I will
generally agree with that statement I
will also point out that Ilhan Omar has
questioned the loyalty of any American
who supports Israel AOC has suggested
you're a bad American if you disagree
with her Ayana Presley over the weekend
suggested that you were disloyal black
person Muslim or gay person if you don't
agree with her so you don't get to throw
around charges of dual loyalty then
objects when other people throw around
charges that you are not loyal to the
country hey here is AOC however making
this case weak minds and leaders
challenge loyalty to our country in
order to avoid challenging and debating
the policy this president does not know
how to make the argument that Americans
do not deserve health care he does not
know how to defend his policies so what
he does is attack us personally okay she
literally attack Nancy Pelosi he's a
racist five minutes ago five minutes ago
so none of this rings true but it is
politically smart right this is the only
smart move that they have made
and there's a little bit more that's aa
to Presley then suggests that people
shouldn't take the bait we shouldn't
follow President Trump down this rabbit
hole here's Iona Presley the Ringo star
of the Socialist Beatles here I
encourage the American people and all of
us in this room and beyond to not take
the bait this is a disruptive
distraction from the issues of care
concern and consequence to the American
people that we were sent here with a
decisive mandate from our constituents
to work on ok so this is correct ok so
so far they've they've said all of this
is correct you know this is this is
basically when I said correct I mean
corrected me politically motivated
direction and then Owen Omar she says
listen when I'm criticizing America and
saying America sucks and it's a terrible
horrible racist no they're very bad
place it's because it comes from extreme
love it's cuz I love America uh-huh
here's Ilhan omar saying this every
single statements that we make is from a
place of extreme love for every single
person in this country part of the
mandate of why we ran for office and why
we got elected except the Jews okay so
they start off and this is their message
and the message is Donald Trump is a
very mean man who says mean things and
makes the country not unified okay that
is the correct political take and then
the Train begins to derail and you see
that front wheel slip off the rails just
a little bit and soon it's chasing
Harrison Ford down the side of the track
as he jumps into a ravine trying to
escape his shackles is how the fugitive
begins okay so
Ilhan Omar leads it off because Omar is
the one who can control herself the
least among the among this group and
when I say she can control herself least
I mean she says the most radical thing
she says the most ridiculous things
she's the most openly anti-semitic she
can't contain her own disdain for
fundamental American institutions and
for Americans more broadly there's a
reason that she has a nine percent
approval rating among non
college-educated whites and there's a
reason that by the way broadly speaking
she is not popular among Americans
because she is deeply off-putting and
that is not a matter of her race Ayana
presley is nowhere near as off-putting
as Ilhan Omar Ln Omar is uniquely
off-putting in the way that she talks
about
that's not so she says that President
Trump he's a white nationalist that's
where she get so here's where the here's
where the squad moves from president
Trump's had a bad xenophobic racist
thing and we don't like that because
America is a great place full of unity
and we're all part of the same family
this is where they moved from there to
Trump's a white nationalist anybody who
supports him is a white nationalist he's
evil he's a sexual abuser and we should
impeach him and Trump's are sitting
there going okay fine
you want this fight like me versus you
guys let's do this thing this is where
Trump is sitting back and grinning like
a Cheshire Cat cuz all President
President Trump has a unique gift
he's the unique gift of turning
everybody else into president Trump's
it's it's like a magic superpower it's
amazing so he says something really
Trump II and then he makes his opponents
instead of using any sort of poise any
sort of moderation he then gets them to
outdo him and make him look like the not
crazy person in the room so here is the
so here is ill Hunnam are saying that
this is all the agenda of white
nationalists well the recent tweets and
words from the president are simply a
continuation of his racist xenophobic
playbook this is the agenda of white
nationalists this is a disruptive
distraction from the issues of care
concern and consequence to the American
spirit so two leaves comment is more on
point I Anna Presley's comment is smart
and then ill Ahana Mars like he's a Nazi
and everybody in the country is going
okay really really he's a Nazi that's
that's what we're going with this this
is the agenda of white nationalist you
guys tried this before it's not gonna
work that's the direction you're moving
in Ilhan Omar going where angels fear to
tread right she immediately charges into
the fray clubbing herself in the face
repeatedly with a political hammer
she says president Trump colluded with
Russia again there's a whole mullah
report on this thing he did not collude
with Russia here she is going right off
those rails man this president who has
been credibly accused of committing
multiple crimes including colluding with
foreign government to interfere with our
election this is a president who has
overseen the most corrupt administration
in our history and pursued an agenda to
allow millions of Americans to die from
a lack of health care while
he transfers millions of dollars in tax
cuts to corporations wise it's bad that
he transfers money he should not
transfer your money
no one should transfer your money nobody
should transfer anything since it's not
a word but in any case no hon Omar go
and write off those rows and then she
goes even further and she goes even
further
she starts listing off Trump's supposed
sins and she can't even get these rights
like guys it's not hard really Trump
says a lot of stupid crap routinely and
they can't help themselves instead you
got el hanim are going you know probably
he was trying to design the v2 missile
that was used by the Nazis to attack
London and L gente mergers going way
over the top here she is talking about
and mischaracterizing every comment that
the president has ever made pretty much
is pretty amazing this is a president
who's called plat black athletes sons of
this no he did not he said that Colin
Kaepernick was a son of a bleep which is
a contention with which I generally
don't like that characterization he
suggests the people who kneel for the
national anthem
our sons of bleeps I don't like them
doing that but I think the language is
inappropriate coming from the President
to the United States but he did not call
all black athletes sons and beliefs
that's a lie she can continue this is a
president who has called black people
who come from black and brown countries
poles okay it's a lie also that is not
true he suggested and it was it was you
know what he suggested is that there
were a bunch of countries in Africa that
were bleep holes okay that is true that
is true there are a lot of bad countries
in Africa okay Somalia is a bad country
too badly run country he did not say
that everyone who is coming from those
places is the bleep hole that is not
what he said is that's not true either
then she continues this is a president
who has equated neo-nazis with those who
protests against them in child's faith
okay that is again not true the
president's big sin in charlottesville
is that he didn't specifically call out
the neo-nazis but he condemned the
neo-nazis he also condemned antifa and
then his big mistake in charlottesville
is that he suggested that there were
good people marching with the people at
Charlottesville who were in that crowd
and that part was not true okay so she
can't even get that part right because
everybody has to seize defeat from the
jaws of victories on real
unreal and then it gets even worse okay
ready it gets even worse we're gonna get
to that in just one second first I'm too
busy to go to the PAS post office okay
the last time I went I got this giant
parking ticket because there's only one
thing the city of Los Angeles is good at
no it is not making sure the law is
enforced it is making sure that I don't
park six inches in a red zone cost like
a hundred bucks if you do that so am I
going to the post office anymore no
instead I'm going in amusing stamps calm
it's fast and it's easy
stamps.com brings all the amazing
services of the US postal office
directly to your computer whether you're
a small office sending invoices and
online seller shipping out products even
a warehouse sending thousands of
packages a day stamps com can handle it
all with ease simply use your computer
to print official US postage 24/7 for
any letter any package any class of mail
anywhere you want to send it once your
mail is ready you just hand it's your
mail carrier or you drop it in the
mailbox it's that simple with stamps
calm you get five cents off every
first-class stamp and up to 40% off
Priority Mail over 700,000 small
businesses are already using stamps calm
right now my listeners get a special
offer that includes a four week trial
plus free postage and the digital scale
no long term commitment just go to
stamps com click on that microphone at
the top of the homepage type in Shapiro
that is stamps.com enter Shapiro for
that special deal it is indeed a
fantastic deal and again you don't want
to get a parking ticket at the post
office so go make it happen for yourself
alrighty so it gets even worse for the
squad so the squad started off with
Trump's divisive then they got to
Trump's a neo-nazi white supremacist
bigot who hates black athletes and then
ill head Omar starts talking about how
he is a bile of garbage how the stuff is
pile of garbage that comes out of trumps
mouth this is clip 22 it's all it's all
a bile it's its bile and garbage here
they are we can either continue to
enable this president and report on the
bile of garbage that comes out of his
mouth or we can hold him accountable to
his crimes the they say that is it is
bile and it is garbage okay and then
they move beyond that then they move
beyond that and they reopen the battle
they had with Nancy Pelosi so one of the
things Nancy Pelosi has been militating
against from the squad one of the things
they
fighting against from the squad is
impeachment because Americans don't want
impeachment they say you want to get rid
of them we have an election next year
we're not interested in impeachment
because you have no impeachable offenses
and sorry you saying mean to him saying
mean things to members of the squad the
poor babies him saying mean things to
members of the squad who are in
immensely powerful have a huge platform
have a bullhorn our shaping American
politics in new ways him saying mean
things about them no matter how mean
that is not grounds for impeachment it
isn't okay that's what Nancy Pelosi was
saying but the squad want impeachment
and that was one of the reasons why
Pelosi kept saying them you know guys
can't just like put down on that that's
a mistake the squad just rushing in like
idiots here's Ilhan omar suggesting it's
time to impeach the president so it is
time for us to stop allowing this
president to make a mockery out of our
constitution it's time for us to impeach
this president ah the pile of garbage
because he says mean things will impeach
him as opposed to Ilhan omar who is a
blatant vicious anti-semite who says
ants medic things every five seconds and
nearly got condemned by her own party
but they wouldn't cuz they're gutless
she's calling for impeachment and then I
Anna Presley jumps on board says I'm not
gonna refer to him as the president he's
not my president okay I thought Barack
Obama was a terrible president I thought
he was a garbage president I really
disliked his administration was he my
president yeah he was legitimately
elected that means he's my president too
here's Ayana Presley saying he's not my
president yeah let's see how this is
gonna play from our colleagues to our
neighbors we are grateful for your
solidarity your encouragement and your
support in the face of the most recent
xenophobic bigoted remarks from the
occupant of our White House I will
always refer to him as the occupant as
he is only occupying space it is not
embody the grace the empathy the
compassion the integrity that that
office requires and that the American
people deserve
okay so here's not he's not my president
so this is the this is what they want to
do this is the direction they want to go
and then Rasheeda Talib she joins the
crowd she says yeah it's time to impeach
Trump let's impeach him
so gonna reopen this panel with Nancy
Pelosi so just to trace this arc we went
from AOC at war with Nancy Pelosi to
trump at war with the squad and now
we're gonna be back at the squad at war
with Nancy Pelosi it's gonna be
fantastic here's her sheet at sleep
combing for impeachment many members of
Congress have called for his impeachment
because of his utter disregard and
disrespect of the United States
Constitution and despite this and other
many attempts to distract us I remain
focused we remain focused on holding him
accountable to the laws of this land and
accountable to the American people
I heard urge House leadership many of my
colleagues to take action to impeach
this lawless president today
okay so there's gonna be now the squad
going back to our Nancy Pelosi again the
cycle of stupidity it's the circle of
dumb it's unbelievable it's unbelievable
and yet all too believable and all too
wonderful it is the sewage flowing back
up through the drain of our guest house
shower that is our politics it is the
dumbest nonsense in the world okay and
as we will see it's kind of what
President Trump wants they just gave
President Trump what he wants is now the
battle is between Trump and the squad
you know who Americans like less than
Donald Trump the squad we didn't get to
that in just one second first hiring
used to be hard not anymore when someone
makes the slightest most minor most
insignificant mistake here on the Ben
Shapiro show unless they are Michael
moles they know how easily we can
replace them
thanks to zip recruiter zip recruiters
comm slash Daily wires where you can try
it out Ellison it's not just about
getting rid of people who suck and
replacing them with people who are
better sometimes it's just about finding
great employees zip recruiter sends your
job posting to over a hundred of the
web's leading job boards but they don't
stop there as applications roll in zip
recruiter analyzes each one they spot
like the top candidates so you never
miss a great match
zip recruiter is so effective that four
out of five employers who post on zip
recruiter can equality Kansas it through
the site within the very first day right
now my listeners can try zip recruiter
for free at this exclusive web address
zip recruiter comm daily wire that's zip
recruiter comm slash Dai ly WI re zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire zip
recruiters indeed the smartest way to
hire why waste time on all these job
boards we can do it with basically a
click
check it out right now at zip recruiter
comm slash daily where are we here at
the daily where you zip recruiter there
is a reason zip recruiter comm slash
daily wear so in a second I'm gonna show
you president Trump and how he has
morphed his argument now and how the
Democrats are stepping directly into the
argument it's unreal unreal but first
we're gonna have to go ahead and
subscribe over it's a Lee Weyer when you
do you get all the goodies get the rest
of this show live you get two additional
hours of the show every afternoon if
you're a Media Matters subscribe you
gets a clip my show and then use it to
jazz up your basement all sorts of
goodies for you when you subscribe you
can also when you get the aerial
subscription get this the very greatest
and beverage vessels leftist here's hot
or cold tumbler overflowing and new
every single day it's pretty incredible
you go check all of that out get our
Sunday special early on Saturday you get
to be part of our mailbag on Fridays all
sorts of goodies when you become a
subscriber also you're helping us
insulate ourselves from the vicissitudes
of the nasty left who seek to destroy
the show on literally a daily basis when
you become a subscriber you're joining
the team in making sure you can get the
content you love go over to daily we're
calm right now and subscribe we're the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
all right so the Democrats now pushing
for impeachment so President Trump is
pushing back and he's shifting his
argument so his argument is shifting
from they should go back to their home
countries which was his original
controversial tweet to if they don't
like the country they can leave and well
I don't typically like this sort of
language I don't like it like if Barack
Obama had said anyone who doesn't like
my administration come away anybody
doesn't like the country well they can
pick off the problem is that the the
argument is so malleable that can it can
be applied to virtually anyone like what
sort of criticism is so bad that people
should now I do think if there's
criticism of the country that is so
ridiculous like let's overthrow the
Constitution right like they like
America is deeply innately unchangeably
evil unless we destroy everything in
erect a different utopian scheme that
sort of stuff is is actually in line
with the if you don't like anything
about America what the hell are you
doing here I get the sentiment for sure
but the problem is the argument is too
malleable but it is also an argument and
that is going to the elasticity and
durability of that argument are going to
rely heavily on who you're targeting
with it so in other words if you say
about somebody like no I'm Chomsky if
you don't like the country you can take
off anytime that has a little bit more
weight than if you just say about Chuck
Schumer if you don't like the country
you can take off anytime in other words
the more radical you are the more you
want to overthrow the fundamental
essence of the United States the more
that argument carries weight the more
that emotional appeal carries weight
well then you gotta pick your targets
specifically and president Trump has
done that with people like Johan Omar
who speaks horribly about the United
Center - say something nice about the
United States it really she doesn't do
it very frequently and Trump knows this
what I oughta Presley is going around
saying that you're not truly black if
you don't agree with her that's not a
great thing so presidents from picks
radical he's not picking the Democratic
Party now it's not hard to find them
he's going and he's finding the the
worst nuts in the Democratic Party and
then he is saying those people should
leave and then the entire democratic
infrastructure is coming around those
people in defense and Trump has now
turned this into a fight between Trump
and who el hen Omar and AOC and Rasheeda
Talib and Ayanna Presley that's a fight
Trump wants is the argument that he was
making yesterday if they don't like the
country they can
happy I'm watching them all they do is
complain
so all I'm saying is if they want to
leave they can leave John they can leave
these are people that in my opinion hate
our country now you can say what you
want but get a list of all of the
statements they've made and all I'm
saying that if they're not happy here
they can leave they can leave and you
know what I'm sure there will be many
people that won't miss them but they
have to love they have to love our
country their Congress people okay so
the truth is one of the reasons that
this argument is kind of dumb is they're
elected so people voted for them and
then just magically appear in Congress
by themselves but the argument carries
emotional weight dependent on how
radical these Democrats decide to be
Trump says listen it's not good for the
Democratic Party that they're rallying
around these figures these are people
that hate our country hey John they hate
our country they hate it
I think with a passion now it's possible
I'm wrong the voter will decide but when
I hear the way they talk about our
country when I hear the anti-semitic
language they use when I hear the hatred
they have for Israel and the love they
have for enemies like Al Qaeda then you
know what I will tell you that I do I do
not believe this is good for the
Democrat Party certainly it's not the
party that I've known over the years nay
and you can hear the media of course
shouting about all this is the fight
Trump wants I mean this is what he will
answer and he tweets about this because
President Trump never says the quiet
part quietly he always says it out loud
she says the Democrats are trying to
distance themselves from the floor
progressives but now they're forced to
embrace them that means they are
endorsing socialism hate of Israel and
the United States not good for the
Democrats as he put that out on Twitter
and here's the thing the the way that
that argument plays is going to be
largely dependent on how these Democrats
hack because now he's specifically
calling them out now when he refers to
al-qaeda what he's presumably referring
to is a clip of Ilhan Omar from several
years back when she was discussing
terrorist groups and she was sort of
mocking the idea that we should take al
Qaeda and Hezbollah and Hamas seriously
it's a really off-putting clip it's
pretty terrible so
tomorrow yesterday at this press
conference who specifically asked
whether she would condemn al Qaeda and
whether she was a communist and here was
her answer respond to some of the
president's specific claims most notably
that you're a communist and that you're
Pro al Qaeda you might have noticed how
when he said go back to where you came
from there was an uproar through the
through all of our communities because
every single person who's brown and
black at some point in their life in
this country
heard that now when he made the comment
I know that every single Muslim who has
lived in this country and across the
world has heard that comment and so I
will not dignify it with an answer okay
so she won't dignify it with an answer
imagine if Trump were asked that
question really imagine Trumper asked
that question about the cake okay we
don't have to imagine it happened and it
was a massive uproar during the 2016
campaign he was asked there's a person
from all from from the KKK David Duke
who has expressed support for you what
do you have to say about the KKK what do
you think Trump would have done if he
had said I'm not gonna dignify that with
a response what do you think the media
would have said never said well why not
why don't you just condemn them so why
doesn't I mean literally yesterday aoc
tweeted out she tweeted out that if you
were silent about Trump's comments that
meant that you approved of Trump's
comments so here is Ilhan omar saying
I'm not going to dignify a question
about whether I am in favor of al Qaeda
with a response she did write a letter
back I'm not saying she's Pro al Qaeda
but she's not answering the question
she isn't okay and the fact is that she
did in fact write a letter in support of
shorter terror sentences for people who
are trying to join Isis just a few years
back suggesting that that Isis were
radical change makers and we read the
letter on air it was printed in the
Minneapolis star-tribune
and then this all of it again is it the
juxtaposition is Trump declaring that
these women are America haters and so
this is when you would assume that they
would say listen we love America so much
America is a wonderful place and Trump
is running it right that's it's an easy
answer but instead you get moments like
this so you
today as I mentioned on the show over
the weekend there was an attack on a
nice facility in Tacoma Washington this
attack on a nice facility was carried
out by Nancy for terrorists is a 69 year
old guy who walked up with the rifle and
he had a propane tank and he tried to
blow up a wall of the ice facility and
while Ilhan Omar was asked by a reporter
from the rebel media whether she could
condemn whether she would condemn this
attempted terror attack on a nice
facility and here's how it would will
you condemn the antifa attack in
Washington over the weekend it's easy to
condemn terrorism will you condemn it
[Music]
and Tifa fire bombed a facility in
Tacoma over the weekend it's an ice
facility will you condemn them for that
I mean to fire bombing a concentration
camp is kind of a laudable thing if it
actually is concentration camp you must
be happy that they did it no are you
pleased should more people do it it's
easy to say no it's very easy for her to
say that she condemns all violence how
do I know that it's very easy because
aoc did it this morning
so she was asked by The Daily Caller so
AO sees first answer was the same as
Omaha no Mars she ran away and so
yesterday a OC was asked over and over
whether she condemned the antifa attack
on a nice facility and here's what that
sounded like again the reporter from the
rebel media will you condemn NT fit for
the attack in Washington
it's easy to condemn a terrorist attack
will you be condemning auntie
they firebombed an American facility
will you condemn them okay in total
silence from AOC ready took our full 24
hours to come up with yes it turns out a
terrorist attack is bad and then the
same question was asked to Ayanna
Presley and the exact same result so
here is Ayana Presley asked to condemn
the anti futurus again by the rebel
media no answer really simple question
will you condemn and Tifa for attacking
a nice facility
it's very simple will you tell Americans
not to attack violently ice facilities
Joe she's getting right next to her I
mean she it's not like she can't hear
the question thing to say I guess keep
walking wait to tell Americans that
you're not sympathetic to an Tifa okay
and nothing no answer none
and then Trump says these people don't
like America okay so what do you expect
the American people to take away from
that these are very easy answers if the
squad wants to take the lead in this
fight this is an easy fight to make if
you are willing to say easy things but
I'm not sure what I'm supposed to take
away from the squad when you've got
Ayane Presley over the weekend
suggesting that black people are not
truly black unless they agree with her
we've got Ilhan Omar and Rashida to lead
blatant anti-semites when you got AOC
who has suggested that we have
concentration camps on our border and
when every member of the squad who's
asked by a reporter yesterday whether
they would condemn an auntie Fattah
attack on American soil went totally
silent it's very easy it truly is if you
ask me if I condemn a terror attack you
know how long it takes me to answer half
a second because it's very easy it's
supremely simple this is what Trump
wants out of this and they're giving it
directly to him it's unbelievable if
2020 turns into a fight between Trump
and the squad and it's just Trump versus
the squad that is the fight that Trump
wants and that's the that's the fight
they're giving him why because they
didn't have anything like the political
acumen to simply take a backseat let
Nancy Pelosi handle it they could've
just let Nancy Pelosi go out front and
say how dare you attack my members this
way these are duly elected members of
Congress who are loyal to the United
States it's nasty to question the
loyalty of people who serve in Congress
in subtweet oh hey Nomar there who's
done it repeatedly but they couldn't do
it they had to be out in the spotlight
and just like president Trump feels the
necessity to be right in the center of
the camera lens these folks feel the
necessity to be in the center of the
camera lens and they make a lot of
mistakes and they don't look good and
the American people don't like it very
much they find it incredibly off-putting
as well they should again their folks
who are gonna say well you know they're
not saying they're in favor of the
antiva attacks well let me play you a
clip of Chuck Schumer yesterday so
you're Senate Minority Leader Chuck
Schumer of New York he said with regard
to president Trump's comments here was
his logic with regard to
two Republicans remain silence on
Trump's comment the president's comments
demand Comden nation from all corners of
the political spectrum all corners but
it's become frightened ly common for
many of my Republican colleagues to let
these moments sail by without saying
even a word so I'm left to wonder if the
silence of many Republicans in the wake
of President Trump xenophobic tweets is
out of embarrassment or agreement
embarrassment or agreement both are
inexcusable okay so according to the
democratic logic silent is acquiescence
silence is acquiescence according to the
democratic logic if that's the case then
why are you remaining silent when asked
if you contaminant Aoife attack on a
nice facility now the real reason I
think that some of these Democrats won't
simply just come out and condemn it or
that it takes them 24 hours to do so is
because there is a segment to the left
that is actually fine with the anti-shah
tax on those facilities and sees it as
heroic namely the most radical wing of
the Democratic Party so Shaun King as
they call him talcum X hey Shaun King
went on Twitter and he and he named the
the attempted they call him that by the
way because he is extraordinarily
radical on race and may or may not be
actually a white person genetically in
any case Shaun King he tweeted out that
this so-called that this aunty Fay
terrorist quote just became the first
martyr attempting to liberate imprisoned
refugees from a for-profit detention
center in Tacoma Washington his hero was
John Brown the white abolitionist who
led the raid on Harpers Ferry in 1859
this is what our country has come to so
first off as somewhat of an a-minor
expert on John Brown John Brown was
fighting a thing called slavery slavery
is where a bunch of people were actually
enslaved against their will you know
what is not that people attempting
voluntarily to immigrate to the United
States we're temporarily held in
detention facilities deliberately
underfunded by Democratic Congress
people second attempting to burn a
detention facility in which
immigrants are is not an act of heroism
but Shaun King is actually in favor of
the violence Shaun King is in pizza
Trump is just pointing at the Democratic
radicalism and saying okay you want
these guys this is what you're gonna get
these are the people you want these are
the people that you are going to get
Nancy Pelosi knows this why do you think
she's been trying to minimize the impact
of the so-called squad the media know
this which is why they're begging for
some sort of conciliation Nancy Pelosi
and the so called squad you know the
there it's so funny all the members of
the media secretly kind of love the
squad not so secretly and so they're
begging Nancy Pelosi to lay off the
squad the truth is that they should be
begging and they should be doing the
Maureen Dowd thing Maureen Dowd over the
weekend was saying to the squad guys
shut up let Nancy Pelosi do this she's a
pro your amateurs that is correct
so somehow we have reached the point
where the argument morphed from AOC
versus Nancy Pelosi because AOC is
radical and Nancy Pelosi is in this
weird world in which we occupy space the
Nancy Pelosi is currently the moderate
that morphed into xenophobe Trump versus
the entire Democratic Party and now that
has morphed into Trump versus the squad
which is the fight that Trump wants and
the squad is radical and they can't
contain their radicalism even long
enough to to limit themselves to that
which is politically beneficial to them
and Trump is going right after it right
I mean Trump is is Trump is making clear
what he's doing here again not hiding
not hiding it he says those tweets were
not racist I don't have a racist bone in
my body the so-called vote to be taken
as a Democrat con game Republicans
should not show weakness and fall into
their trap this should be a vote on the
filthy language statements and lies told
by the Democratic congresswoman I truly
believe based on their actions hate our
country get a list of the horrible
things they've said Omar is polling at
8% cortes at 21% Nancy Pelosi tried to
push them away but now they are forever
wedded to the Democrat Party see you in
2020 well done Democrats somehow you
have spun this so that it's actually now
have I all this fades into the
background the actual contents of the
comments cuz Trump's has so many things
as I've said before his epitaph is gonna
read Donald Trump 45th presidents of the
United States he said a lot of crap all
that fades into the woodwork the
only think people are gonna take into
the ballot box is Trump versus the squad
if Trump has his way and parently
Democrats are just going to allow that
to happen because they are incredibly
dumb okay time for some things I like
and then we'll do some things that I
hate so things that I like today one of
my forms of relaxation of which I have
needed some recently is reading baseball
books there's a good baseball book out
by kevin cook called 10/10 innings at
Wrigley the wildest ball game ever with
baseball on the brink talking about the
a game between the Philadelphia Phillies
and the Chicago Cubs circa 1980 now the
final score was 23 to 22 the Cubs were
actually trailing by 12 runs in that
game came back to tie it and then ended
up losing it in the ninth Dave Kingman
hit three home runs it's it's a really
fun good book I love sports books
because there's nothing that is kind of
more involving or distracting than then
sports and so you can check it out Kevin
cooks 10 innings at Wrigley you can go
check that out it's a lot of fun okay
time for some things that I hate so the
pandering grows strong with the
democrats marianne williamson who i will
admit i stan marianne williamson
marianne williamson is great because she
says crazy stuff on a national stage
when i say crazy I don't think
politically crazy as much as she's very
weird and she says weird things a lot
and it's kind of kooky and fun she was
on that stage talking about how she was
gonna rope Trump with chains of love or
something it was pretty fantastic she
isn't out polling ahead of beta overwork
in New Hampshire which is just fantastic
beta Roark is the Steve Harrington post
High School of the Democratic race in
high school he was the hair right in
high school he was the guy all the girls
wanted to be with he's the coolest kid
in school and now he's just an
unemployed loser working in an ice cream
shop wearing navy shorts and that that's
beta work but marianne williamson has
climbed all the way up to like 4.5% in
new hampshire which is just phenomenal
now the downside to marianne williamson
is that as a kooky person she is also a
kooky person and she also because she
channels this sort of karmic leftism she
sometimes says things out loud that are
weird so she had an event yesterday and
this is pretty internal it shows where
the democratic
Ardi truly is where we are going my
goodness and Marian Wilson at this event
calls on all the white members of her
audience to surround the black members
of the audience and then repeat a formal
apology after her so first of all I'm
not a big fan of people generally
repeating what politicians have to say I
just think that it is creepy and weird I
remember the Donald Trump did it in 2016
i critiqued it at the time I do not like
it when politicians say repeat after me
and then we've got a huge crowd of
people repeating after them unless
you're actually taking a citizenship
oath or something it's really dumb but
this is even more ridiculous marianne
williamson informs all the white people
in the room they need to apologize to
all the black people in the room and it
gets very awkward I'm going to ask the
white Americans in the room to please
repeat after me
on behalf of myself and on behalf of my
country
to you and all african-americans please
hear this from my heart I apologize
please forgive us what in the actual F
what okay I've had a slogan for the
Democratic Party ever since Donald Trump
won in 2016 all you guys had to do was
not be crazy that was it you just had to
not be crazy and now you're having full
struggle sessions where all the white
members of the audience are having
Maoist struggle sessions where they go
up to black members of the audience
surround them in the creepiest possible
fashion and then inform them that they
are apologizing on behalf of the country
at the behest of a kooky spiritual guru
like Marianne Williamson by the way I
mean it I wonder how the black folks in
the audience feel about this do they
like it and do they not like if you're a
black member of the audience like if I
were let's say I were at some sort of
event in Germany and all of a sudden a
bunch of Germans surrounded me and they
say on behalf of me and Germany I
apologize to you I'd be like why are you
apologizing to me I wasn't here you
weren't here either probably unless
you're an actual Nazi and you can
remember my family and you were involved
in World War two I'm not sure what you
are apologizing for does she does
Marianne Williamson know the histories
of anybody in that room like does she
know whether the black people in that
room were actually descended from slaves
for example are they new newer
immigrants to the United States like
Kamala Harris for the commo Harris
appearance right , Harris is born here
about her parents well not like does she
know the history of any of the white
people in that room
does she know whether any of them maybe
died in the Civil War their ancestors
does she know whether those people may
be new immigrants themselves maybe they
were discriminated against but this sort
of this sort of bizarre
quasi religious politics it's weird and
it's off-putting but I guess it's
attractive to a certain percentage of
the Democratic base Marianne Williamson
is the it of the Democratic Party at
this point and it is a weird place to be
it's very odd find the nearest black
person
College eyes to them really that's where
that's what we're going but that's not
advice if on the basis of race by the
way apparently so that's that's good
stuff meanwhile Joe Biden who again his
entire campaign the only reason he's in
the race is to provide some semblance of
normal tea supposedly Joe Biden still
holding to this narrow lead nationally
he's holding to a very narrow lead in
New Hampshire apparently he's in a near
statistical tie with Elizabeth Warren
and Kamala Harris he's fallen behind
Kamala Harris in California he had a big
lead a month ago in California
Camille Harris is the odds-on favorites
win the nomination at this point we'll
get to her in just one second but Joe
Biden all he had to do was not be weird
and he can't do it so he was asked about
how he was going to challenge President
Trump what would happen if President
Trump challenged him on the basis of his
age because Biden is less energetic as a
person than Donald Trump is Trump has
some sort of connection to the upside
down from what she draws energy because
the man has never exercised in his life
and he eats only garbage and yet like
the flux capacitor in the DeLorean he is
powered by that garbage to an
extraordinary extent so joe biden was
asked how you gonna deal with Trump's
energy level and Joe Biden aside said
I'm basically gonna be as weird as
possible he starts making fun of your
age your mental state he starts going
after you in a way is that this is I
mean come on Donald come on man how many
pushups you wanna do here pal you know
I'm jokingly you know come on run with
me man it's like I was in a in a parade
in Independence Missouri and I and I
always run in parades that's the way I
go back and forth and this fellow from
my independence was the Trump supporter
said hey maybe Joe I said come round
with me Jack come on man um come run
with me Jack come on so Donald Trump
would say to you you're too old and
you're kooky and your response to be
let's do some hold people push-ups let's
sit let's get out there and I'll do like
a pull-up with one hand and then uh all
they had to do was not be weird all they
had to do is not be weird and this is
why eventually when the 2020 race is
over it will be the ghosts of Cecil the
lion who his presidents of the United
States cuz all anyone had to do
not be crazy and no one could do it by
the way Joe Biden has lost it he has
lost it hey yesterday he was on the
campaign trail and he is now repeating
the same lies that he repeated back in
2012 about Obamacare he's launching what
he calls the Affordable Care Act 2.0
which does raise the question what was
wrong with the Affordable Care Act 1.0 I
thought that was supposed to solve all
our problems
it did not here was Joe Biden talking
about it and using exactly the same way
he used the first time how many of you
have when you were working like your and
you may still be working many of you how
many of you like your employer based
health care did you think it was
adequate now if I come along and say
finish you can't have it anymore well
that's what Medicare for all does you
cannot put have it period number one
there was a hiatus spot in between by
the way how long it's going to take so
I'd leave people the option if you like
your health care plan and your employer
based plan you can keep it if in fact
you have private insurance you can keep
it so if you like your plan you can keep
it if you like your doctor you can keep
it if you're like them you can keep them
remember a person who said that and was
lying to you so Joe Biden telling the
exact same lines yeah that campaign is
falling apart and he's gonna be bashed
over the head about all of this by the
other members of the Democratic Party
well that means that what this is
turning into is a two-person race and
Joe Biden in one of those people the
two-person race is going to be Elizabeth
Warren and Camille Harris Warren is
picking up an enormous amount of support
from the Bernie Sanders base Bernie
Sanders has fallen all the way down to
fifth place in New Hampshire he should
be winning New Hampshire New Hampshire
is right next door to Vermont
he should be winning New Hampshire he is
not in fact winning New Hampshire he is
now dropped behind Peabody judge in New
Hampshire so Bernie Sanders is falling
apart Elizabeth Warren is picking up
support Elizabeth Warren also happens to
be deeply dishonest this is one of the
beauties about being a politician is
that you have bitch'll Eli so according
to BuzzFeed news Elizabeth Warren's
campaign turned to a big donor to pay
for the DNC voter database
apparently Warren relied on a
multi-million dollar Democratic donor to
cover the cost of an expensive voter
database a move that risks putting her
campaign at odds with the spirit if not
the letter of the pledge she made to
abstain from big-money fundraising in
February just two months into her
presidential campaign
Warren sent herself apart from the rest
of the Democratic field by swearing off
the kind of pay-for-play fundraising
that typically gives wealthy donors
outsized access and influence according
to BuzzFeed news Warren officials now
say she didn't violate that pledge when
her campaign turned to one of
California's top Democratic donors a
well ISA wealthy Silicon Valley
physician named Carla Jurvetson to help
pay for access to a crucial voter
database earlier this spring that
database cost 175 grand and she went to
one Democratic donor who contributed 7
million dollars to Democrats in 2018 and
got the money from that person so
Elizabeth Warren all in favor of small
money donations until it comes time to
pay the bills speaking of which Camille
Harris has the same sort of problem so
we all know that Kamala Harris is truly
dishonest she's been dishonest on her
position on federal bussing which she
has switched several times she's been
dishonest on her position on getting rid
of private health care insurance which
he has also switched several times and
now it turns out she is dishonest when
it comes to raising money herself
according to the Associated Press Kamala
Harris bemoaned the influence of the
powerful and connected elite last
Tuesday when she called on top Justice
Department officials to recuse
themselves from any matter related to
Jeffrey Epstein she said they're former
law firms work on behalf of the
financière accused of sexual abuse calls
into question the integrity of our legal
system and then she cashed the check the
same exact day Harris's husband
headlined a Chicago fundraiser for her
presidential campaign that was hosted by
six partners of that firm Kirkland and
Ellis according to an invitation
obtained by The Associated Press
Harris was one of several White House
hopefuls to blast the handling of
Epstein's case in Florida a decade ago
when his lawyers negotiated a deal with
federal prosecutors but her decision to
move ahead with the fundraiser hosted by
Kirkland and Ellis partners while
criticizing the firm underscores the
tension that can arise when a
politician's rhetoric collides with his
or her need to raise money to sustain a
presidential campaign so turns out that
Harris while she was ripping Kirkland
and Ellis was taking their money
she was effectively Claude Rains in
Casablanca she's shocked shocked to find
that law is going on here
here are your winnings sir thank you
very much it's a good stuff from Camille
Harris and Elizabeth Warren so which of
these candidates is best positioned to
take on a president Trump yeah who the
hell knows I mean it's difficult to tell
at this point considering how radical
they are now it would behoove the
- simply pointed them is what he's now
trying to do he's trying to shift his
original bad point on Sunday into a
better look at that squad over there
those guys are the worst and they're the
heart of the Democratic Party that's a
smart move by Trump but the Democrats
would be best doing is just pointing at
Trump so we could have a race in which
they point at each other or we could
have a race where everybody just clubs
themselves in the head in the head with
a wooden mallet until the little Tweedy
burbs appear around their ears I have a
feeling we are going to move toward the
ladder very quickly given the tenor of
today's politics already we'll be back
here a little bit later today we have
two additional hours of content a lot of
goodies coming up for you then so I'll
see you then this is the Ben Shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Savitz audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
19 hey guys over on the Matt Walsh show
today and antifa member just waged a
terrorist attack against the government
facility
prominent Democrats have refused to
condemn this terrorist assault by an
antifa member and of course is
horrifying that they refused to condemn
it but why do they refuse to condemn the
answer to that question is even more
horrifying also Joe Biden reveals his
stunning historical ignorance and
finally I'll explain why I think we
should all stop watching Disney films
don't call it a boycott it's not a
boycott it's just a matter of
self-respect
that's all and I'll explain that today
over on the Matt Walsh show